the attacks in afghanistan and the
ultimate sacrifice paid by those killed
are triggering really strong emotions
here at home orco mana joins us now in
orca you spent the afternoon talking to
veterans and how are they doing
well brian many of them say it's hard to
come to terms with what happened in
afghanistan and service members and
local afghans as well are devastated but
they're holding on to hope
very challenging very heartbreaking
that's the only way rokha yousafzai can
describe how he is feeling right now he
has family caught in the chaos in
afghanistan they were on their way to
the airport
to make another attempt to be able to
get out but the deadly blast outside
kabul's airport thursday made that
impossible yousafzai has not been able
to connect with his loved ones since
then so he's holding on to their most
recent conversation they still had hopes
that they could make it to the gates
thirteen u.s service members were killed
in the attacks the deadliest day for the
u.s military in a decade no we're just
feeling frustrated
angry frustrated sad all those things
jonell doreles is a retired u.s air
force helicopter pilot who served two
tours in afghanistan in the early 2000's
he's still processing the loss of life
as a former service member and american
that hits hard dorellis tells me after
being on the ground in afghanistan years
ago he never expected things to get to
this point he wants to see more
organization i don't argue that it was
time to get out it was just done poorly
very poorly and unfortunately you know
what happened today is the end result of
that but he's hopeful we're going to get
our people out we're going to get our
friends out yousafzai prays that's true
for his family we need to figure out how
we can get them out of there
now president biden plans to retaliate
against those who caused the attack and
the u.s air force pilot that i spoke to
says he hopes the president
delivers on that promise reporting live
tonight orca mana 8 news now